foreign
I think they premiered it on Twitter
uh it's like I don't think it was a
Twitter Premiere I think it was
announced on Twitter and it was a rumble
Premiere but that doesn't really matter
it premiered somewhere this week you and
I have both seen it I will tell you I
accidentally I was watching on my phone
and there was I was trying to get out of
a mode in which you saw all of the
comments scrolling through and I hit a
button that I did not realize was
retweet and the next comment I saw was
Brett Weinstein has retweeted this so I
immediately deleted that tweet but
anybody who saw it because they have an
alert targeted at me or because of the
vagaries of Twitter don't take that as
any indication of anything was
non-intentional and you can tell that
because I deleted it within seconds
um but
I did want to give some guidance on how
to think about this thing I had a
conclusion you and I have not talked
about what your conclusion might be so
just I mean for those
it's called died suddenly and it's it's
about
uh the effects that the filmmakers
um purport to see from a variety of
sources uh of the widespread adoption of
the covet vaccines right now I'm alarmed
about this documentary uh I would say at
two levels of alarm
one I believe it contains something
potentially very very important
and it has fused that something to
things that make it suspect yeah
the thing that I think is very important
and I'm not saying that this is true but
I'm saying it would be so easy to
falsify if it wasn't true that if we
can't falsify it that's going to tell us
something that is a kind of piece of
information the thing that it brings to
light that one needs to take seriously
is the possibility
that morticians are seeing in cadavers a
novel kind of what is being described as
a clock but it's not really a clot white
fibrous white fibrous extremely large
artery and vein blocking both masses you
might call them plaques but in any case
the idea the basics that have internal
coherence and so can be pulled out
right and they apparently have not just
the veins but the artery switches yeah
the consistency of rubber bands or
calamari is how they're being described
now I saw the first place I encountered
this was Stephen Crowder interviewed one
of the same morticians who was talking
about his observation and alarm and his
talk with other
morticians and what I would say is
this film made by a guy named Stu
s-t-e-w Peters isn't it
um he's at least one of The Producers
right who I don't follow I don't even
really recognize him except that there
was an earlier thing where he was
involved in advancing a story about
snake venom and uh the vaccines that
turned out to be nonsense
um a story that we also didn't uh back
or believe in
any case
the
um mortician reports these calamari-like
clots there's lots of footage of them
not only preserved in vials but in this
film there's footage of them being
pulled from cadavers could that be faked
of course it could be faked on the other
hand it has it raises a relatively
obvious question
are there morticians who are not seeing
this who will come forward and saying
yeah not seeing it in my Mortuary right
there ought to be lots of those if this
is fake and what I will tell you is the
people that I don't know well but that
I'm in conversation with have friends in
the the so-called death carry industry
who validate the story that these things
exist so if these things exist and the
timing of them
is what it appears to be which is to say
not consistent with it being a coveted
phenomenon yes consistent with it being
a post-vaccine phenomenon then it needs
to be investigated it is utterly
unambiguous that this is an important
question and the problem is that this
film
overtly almost fuses it to utter
nonsense right it fuses it there's like
a montage in the beginning with Bigfoot
and 911 stuff and I can't remember what
else but it was like a smorgasbord I
don't know how you pronounce that
Smorgasbord I think only if you're the
the chef and the Muppets I pronounce it
that way I am not but in any case it
fuses it to these other things and
um so I read that as there's lots of
kooky ideas out there and some of them
turn out to be true right with them not
I read that opening montage
generously Perhaps Perhaps too
generously as we the makers of this film
may or may not believe in the you know
conspiracy theories that you will
associate with footage of 9 11 of
Sasquatch of the moon landing of this
that the other but uh you know the
Kennedy assassination and let me just
you know add that one in there because
you know Kennedy assassination which is
one that
I think a large proportion of Americans
are like yeah that was especially
Americans with brains
um yeah so yeah I would say actually let
me just add one in there where like I'm
comfortable saying yeah that is not what
the Warren Commission said it was right
right
my point would be unfortunately I think
your mind is playing a trick on you
where it is rationalizing away an
unforgivable
um connection right if this calamari
clock thing is for Real then it needs to
exist on its own so that we can figure
out what it implies about the rest of
our models of this thing that we didn't
know yet to in any way bring it close to
anything Preposterous like Bigfoot which
I would rate the likelihood of Bigfoot
being real in the Pacific Northwest
um as extremely unlikely just in light
of the fact that we never find skulls or
skeletons or get a good picture or
whatever and we know that people have
hoaxed you know and so I mean you're now
you're now in it because you're now
going to get the Bigfoot Community
coming after us but luckily it doesn't
look good in the actual Bigfoot so yeah
exactly I'd be more concerned but
anyway point being unforgivable to fuse
those things also unforgivable to take
incredibly important sources like
um like Peter McCullough Michael like
Ryan Cole
um Steve Kirsch to have these people in
a film in which low quality stuff
garbage stuff and this very important
observation yeah so there's there's a
few errors right like we have an uh the
that's I don't even remember what it is
that they're showing but they're talking
about some very unlikely events that
have actually happened yeah and three
times in a row like the probability is a
zero and I was actually yelling at my
computer like duh don't do that right
like no you know the probability cannot
be zero of the thing that happened right
they right they basically are making an
argument a correct argument about the
number of standard deviations out we are
and therefore how unlikely this is and
then they are synonym they're basically
rounding to zero right right and it's
yeah you don't round to zero in fact
it's exactly the subject of this episode
of Dark Horse that we've been talking
about the point is you can have a very
very low probability and it's not the
same thing as zero
um but
anyway so what I'm gonna I still think I
have knees though
not if this is a simulation you don't
I mean I think the simulation of me and
the simulation thinks I have needs oh
yeah there's too many simulations let's
agree that you either have knees or
simulated knees but
um no it's really three it's knees
simulated knees or imaginary knees I
mean you could be a schizophrenic
quadriplegic who thinks they have knees
the quadriplegic still at knees they
just don't work oh uh amputee double
amputee yeah thanks sorry I'm just
trying to be complete about the various
hypotheses here believe me the one I
believe in is the one that you have
knees
yes yes but anyway my advice to our
audience was going to be actually as
much as I would like to tell you don't
watch this film because we don't know
what it is
the clot stuff the pseudo clock whatever
these structures are rubber band
calamari whatever it is watch it
evaluate for yourself what are the
chances that these morticians it's not
an infinite number of morticians in this
uh piece what are the chances that they
are not what they appear that they're a
plant you know placed to convince us
that these structures are real and that
it will turn out not to be true because
every other mortician in the western
world is going to stand up and tell us
hey wait a second I haven't seen one of
these things right what are the chances
and don't those chances drop every day
that the morticians don't rise up and
denounce this film saying hey those
things aren't real right so
anyway I would say watch the film
um do not let the film color your view
of Ryan Cole of Steve Kirsch of Peter
McCullough
process these things independently and
the film could be malicious nonsense
designed to take this very important and
effectively uncontrovertible and
controvertible piece of evidence and get
rid of it by by muddling it it could be
that process it separately process the
observations the interviews go back and
look at Stephen Crowder's interview and
then watch what develops in the coming
weeks is this being used to get rid of
that evidence by saying oh it's part of
some giant conspiracy theory that
involves Bigfoot and 911 and who knows
don't do that right process the
information that these morticians seem
to be giving you independently
and leave the rest of the film out
because it's not clear even what it is
that's my advice
[Music]